-You got to wrap up
"Will & Grace" the second time
Was it nice to --
to put a button on it again?
-It was great.
Put several buttons,
'cause it's never
gonna happen again, ever,
for as long as we live.
-Oh, you buttoned and a zipper
-Yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
A button, a zipper,
and cement glue.
-And you threw it
in the East River.
It was really sweet, like,
how you guys threw it
in the river like that.
-Yeah, we threw it in the rive
with cement blocks
on the bottom of it.
But we --
No, it was --
You know,
we did that election video
to get out the vote in 2016.
It turned into this thing that
millions of fans wanted to see
We met with the network,
it happened.
Who ever knew that we were
gonna come back and do it?
And it was the closest thing
you could do
to reliving your youth again
-Yeah, and you guys all --
And I mean this genuinely.
You all looked very good
for a group of people
who'd taken that long off
between seasons.
-I know.
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, can you tell me --
I like talking to people
about their early jobs.
You -- What was your job
in a musical --
You were the musical directo
at, like, a dinner theater
-Yeah.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
How did you know that?
So, yeah,
I was the music director
at a place called
Pheasant Run Dinner Theatre.
-Great name.
-Oh, my God, I have
7,000 stories, but, uh...
One of them is --
What's one of them, Scotty
[ Laughs ]
There's so many.
Oh, yes.
-What's --
-This is great.
This is --
Seth, I'm in the middle
of a story.
This is great.
So, I was sitting at home,
and my friends --
Oh, my God.
I gotta speed this up.
Or, let me start it again.
You can cut in, right?
-No, we're not gonna do
any editing.
This is it.
[ Both laugh ]
-Okay. So, really quick.
So, I was the music director
at Pheasant Run Dinner Theatre
in the suburbs of Chicago,
and one day,
I'm sitting at home --
This is before I got the job
I'm sitting at home,
and my friend,
who's the director there,
she calls, she says,
"Can you come finish
the second act of 'Grease'
The musical "Grease."
I'm like, "What do you mean?
She goes, "The piano playe
has tendinitis
and carpal tunnel, and she
can't play the second act.
I'm like, "I don't understan
what you're asking me now.
Are you asking me to come
and sit in front of an audienc
of 500 people, or whatever
and play --
like, sight-read the music
I've never even seen the music."
And she's like,
"Yeah, that's what I am asking
I'm holding intermission now
Instead of a 15-minute
intermission, it's gonna b
a 25-minute intermission.
How fast can you drive here?
And an idiot -- I'm 21 years
old, 20 years old -- 21 --
I don't know --
I go, "I'm doing it.
I'm there."
I'm driving like a maniac
to this theater.
I get there.
The audience is like,
"What's taking so long
from the intermission?
I go down to the pit,
wave to the musicians,
who I have never even met.
I'm like, "Hi. Ready?
Two, three, four, and go."
And I'm reading this music
that I've never seen befor
and missing all the notes,
and everybody who's onstage is
you know...
♪♪ Go, Greased Lightnin' ♪♪
And they're looking at me like
"What are --
Who is this person?"
And I'm hitting
all the wrong notes.
It was the scariest thing
in my life.
-I love that you just embraced
the idea of doing it.
-That's what you do
when you're young and dumb
and that's what you do
when you're old and dumb.
-Yeah, and by the way,
and then you learned from it
Well, or maybe
you didn't learn from it.
Could you play
"Greased Lightnin'" now?
-Well, I'm on your show, so...
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, that's true.
-I guess that's a -- I mean,
I think this is a good --
For anybody at home watching
take chances when you're young
and then, ultimately, end up
in the elevated position
of a Sean Hayes.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
The elevated position?
-Yes.
-Well, I am on a stool.
-Oh.
-I'm a little --
I'm higher than normal.
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, it's always so --
Wait, is that hat --
Sean, is that your initials?
Is it "Sean Hayes"?
-Yes, but isn't that hilarious
It's -- Scotty got it for me
It's really "Southampton."
-Ah.
-But it worked out
that it's also my initials
-[ Laughs ]
-You have -- You have a --
You have "S&M" stuff, right?
-Yeah, and then you just -
you just "S&M,"
but then people say,
"What is that ball gag for?"
I'm like, "Seth Meyers."
-Yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
-"It's not for that."
-No.
-"It's my initials."
-[ Laughing ] Right.
"It's not for my brand."
-It isn't -- It just...
Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
It's always a delight
to talk to you.
-Yes, and, Seth,
you know I love you so much.
I think you are
one of the funniest,
best hosts of all time,
and I genuinely,
truly mean that.
You make me laugh so hard,
and I'm so happy
you ask me to be on your show,
always.
-Oh, my God.
I love you, Sean.
I'll see you soon.
-Okay, bye.